this is this is from newsweek came out
the other day secret commandos with
shoot to kill authority were at the
capitol
on sunday january 3rd the heads of a
dozen elite government special
operations team met in quantico virginia
to go over potential threats
contingencies and plans for the upcoming
joint session of congress the meeting
and the subsequent deployment of these
shadowy commandos on january 6 has never
before been revealed right after the new
year jeffrey rosen the acting attorney
general on january 6 approved
implementation of long-standing
contingency plans dealing with the most
extreme possibilities an attack on
donald trump or vice president mike
pence a terror attack involving a weapon
of mass destruction and a declaration of
measures to implement continuity of
government requiring protection and
movement of presidential successors
rosen made a unilateral decision to take
the preparatory steps to deploy the
justice department's so-called national
forces there was no formal request from
the u.s capitol police the secret
service or the metropolitan police
department in fact no external request
from any agency the leadership injustice
and the fbi anticipated the worst and
decided to act independently special
operations forces lurking behind the
scenes so here's the question i have
with this story if they knew all of this
if they had the foresight to say there
was a very serious threat where was the
national guard where were the capital
police why weren't they sharing
intelligence why weren't they doing
anything to prevent the so-called it's
almost like they wanted it to happen so
i i can i can explain to everybody a
couple of things here if you want um
so there was that bit so right before we
started there was a question of because
i think tim you had seen on the daily
mail the way they categorized this i
think it was daily mail was it may have
been the other one that that trump had
deployed these teams right which changes
things but if you read through what it
states is is that trump had approved the
authority for these teams but
trump approved the authority for these
teams back during the summer of 2020 and
he had put the order in because remember
the riots were going on late may early
june 2020 horrific the city of dc was on
fire hold on trump authorized commandos
with shoot to kill authority because of
the george floyd riots so
yes and no uh well yes right it's not
like it's not like he specifically said
that but this it look this is this what
we would call this is the ncr con conup
so the ncr conop and if tom sauer were
here he would know exactly what i'm
talking about that essentially means if
there is a threat to the national
capital region that's kind of like all
bets are off like this is the head of
the government right so if there is a
threat to the national capital region
that that stuff just in place you just
press the button and boom all this stuff
gets spun up and it gets spun up real
fast and so i believe and i knew and i
reported some of this
back when it happened
but there were reports that the 82nd
airborne was flying airborne remember
those uh helicopters that you saw over
dc during the summer of 2020. so let me
just put it this way if the 82nd is up
in the air who do you think is on those
birds right who do you think is
operating on the ground if you can see
the 82nd up in the air right it's just
one of those like common sense kind of
things like just think about this that's
tier one response because if the head of
government goes down right who else is
left like you need to defend the capital
and so they do not play any jokes they
do not mess around with that stuff and
so we already knew that barr during the
summer of 2020 had taken the step to
deputize
all federal law enforcement agencies
remember this this was reported i know
you've talked about it are you talking
about oregon in
throughout the entire country all three
letter agencies that were 1811. so if
you have an 1811 that means you're a
special agent so if you're
uh customs and border patrol under dhs
if you're a secret service if you're um
even even irs right it has 1811s that's
that's your special agent federal law
enforcement that means i'm federal agent
right federal agent right that's 1811.
so
in 1811 however is not normally tasked
with or your bureau of prisons for
example that's had they have 1811s
you're not usually tasked with defending
the capital barr put forward the this is
the same reason why boratak which is the
special ops unit for the border went up
to oregon right so bard put out this
blanket order so a bunch of these black
and orders were signed during that
period this is one of them however i
don't think trump ever considered that
it would be used at the capitol during
this interesting however because the
authority was already signed rosen
looked at it and said yeah sure send
them the capital they didn't do anything
though
so we know
oh i see see what i think i think the
reason this is why is this coming out in
newsweek now
why when there's been so many questions
about january 6
when this has been front page news even
though by the way the ratings on
anything related to january 6 they're in
the dumpster right nobody in like the
rest of the country is really caring
that much about this and the opinion
polls bear this out
that you have one narrow band of people
that like really really care about it
and they all watch rachel maddow and
enjoy reid and a lot of them are in the
white house currently like ron clayne um
but other than that people have kind of
moved on they care about inflation they
care about the gas prices etc but
suddenly you've got people like like
darren beatty like myself who have been
out there talking about you know tucker
carlson had this huge documentary about
what was going on with federal agents in
terms of this we're one year away from
it we know that the january 6 committee
has been continuing to go after hannity
now they're going after other people
kennedy they knew they are they've
they've just requested his um you know
they've requested his assistance and
then if he doesn't comply that'll be
next episode did they request uh
documents from you
uh i have not been i have not had any
communication with january
uh committee and
then um
where was i on that okay so
they know that something is going to
come out regarding this they'd remember
they all talked called tucker carlson
crazy they said tin foil hair on fire
for suggesting that federal agents from
these agencies may have been involved on
january 6 are involved with any of these
militias or anything like that and now
suddenly we get these people coming out
on their own i see to say well okay we
did have special operations commandos
but they were only there to protect they
were only there to do this and we
guarantee they weren't doing anything
else so you you think that some of these
guys were involved with um effectively
planning or pushing people towards
things like that i don't want to i don't
know i don't want to say that guy's name
necessarily like but there's a guy who
everyone's accusing of being a fed yeah
and i don't even know if it would be
that far but i would guarantee you that
at some level if these guys were doing
their jobs they would be hint they would
be running operations they would be
dressing up plain clothes they would be
going into the crowd they would be
saying hey what are you guys doing after
what are you doing after the after the
thing you guys you going up to the
capitol maybe i think the narrative is
already i think that's all going to come
out well the idea that the doj had
enough foresight to prepare to have
special operations on the ground
suggests that for some reason they did
not have
standard law enforcement police or
national guard that they were they were
so worried about a terror attack that
they get a handful of these commandos
why not go talk to the police and say
hey look we think this is a serious
threat so why don't you beef up security
which by the way in that video says
don't bury the lead there was a terror
attack there were pipe bombs that were
planted on january 5th the night before
at the rnc at the d and the dnc i'm like
you know i get that you want to go after
like rolling up you know uh magami maws
and everything in alaska but i'm a
little bit more worried about who was
planting the pipe bombs
you know
at the heads of our national committees
for both parties the intelligence
agencies definitely lost vegas shooter
that thing yeah yeah stephen paddock the
guy definitely one way of expressing it
largest mass shooting in u.s history and
yet we don't even know anything about
this motive and then the fact the fact
that we had this incident you know all
over washington dc which is a
surveillance grid which is has
surveillance cameras everywhere you had
someone leaving pipe bombs and they
still haven't caught the person next to
the cabinet and people don't know the
capital and where those are located
as well there's a number of pipe bombs
that day and this of course leads to a
lot of speculation a lot of conspiracy
theories that there was a plan b if
something didn't work out that they
would use this as a as a which scott as
you've seen you've seen the blue on
thing on this right yeah who they claim
who it is uh oh no i don't see that you
haven't seen those they claim what's up
there is a blue and on thing out there
where they claim that the pipe bomb
because of
what is it
there there's like some reason that they
say from the video i don't know if it's
the sneakers or the walk or something
blue anon actually claims that the pipe
bomber was marjorie taylor green
i i kid you not
like you can go go look it up they they
actually have i don't know if there's
articles but you can find it on like
tick tock and stuff where they say yeah
the the we think it was marjorie taylor
green and they have these whole theories
and like where was she the night before
etc they're making fake tweets about it
no no no joke daily dot fake tweet
attempts to link marjorie taylor green
to capitalism daily dot is like as far
left crazy as you can go
i'm kind of with you here jack i i think
the federal government is more
implicated here than we nee we even know
about it
wait wait wait look at this same gate
same left arm swing same dropped left
shoulder
shoes look the same turns out it was a
human wait wait wait wait guys guys
dark pants
naturally pants were both worn by
marjorie taylor green that's a shadow
and the pipe bomber casper a shadow
roller
suitcase she has a roller suitcase she
has a roller bag too she also has a
roller bag nobody has a roller nobody
has a roller bag
yeah they stopped using those in the 90s
i mean that's fair now everyone's got
skateboards they carry all their stuff
and individually wrap plastic bags i'm
going to have to be skeptical on this
one i've been watching a lot of
information on
the the bombing of pearl harbor and that
i've heard that the american government
knew there was going to be an attack
they didn't know where so they they were
kind of they just let it happen because
they needed to incite the people to get
angry and go to war and i when i see
these like waiting letting it happen
they knew it was gonna they were there
just in case but they kind of let
something happen it looks like they
obviously didn't stop it
i i can't i can't uh well that's the
whole thing about like admiral leighton
who was the n2 or the j-2 for pacom at
the time who was the intel director out
there before he was admiral he was
commander layton uh my navy buddies are
gonna abandon me for that one he he had
predicted that it would come to pearl
harbor but nobody listened to him yeah
so there's a there's a couple different
ways people address that they say either
we had reason to believe it was ignored
we had intelligence it was ignored or
they outright knew it was about to
happen and said stand down we need it
well it's not that we didn't miss that
the the entire japanese fleet left tokyo
it was the idea is are they going to hit
the philippines are they going to hit
hong kong or are they going to hit
hawaii and what people don't realize
that they actually hit all three at the
same time but but i will say this
because i i i can't speak to that stuff
i will say your the history people think
they know man if you had any idea and
the example i often give is if the news
are fake imagine history
take a look at occupy wall street
occupy wall street the story of what
went on in occupy wall street is
predominantly told by those who favored
occupy wall street the people who
opposed it weren't in the park so there
were very few people who are going to
give you an honest assessment of what
actually happened there and even the
people who might be there as actual
journalists couldn't see the the
entirety of the picture not even i could
not even loot could we were down there
but i'll tell you this the stuff i see
they write about occupying what was
going on i'm like man they just lie
about everything to make it seem good
what's going to happen is it's going to
be 20 30 years and they're going to be
like we're going to read this book on
what happened during occupy wall street
and it's going to be all fluff all the
bad stuff stripped out and i'm sure the
same is true for american history and
for the revolution spanish civil war
spanish civil war there's probably a
whole bunch of really crazy gruesome
awful stuff the americans did during the
war for independence that just doesn't
get told about yeah dude the native
american genesis oh dude the conquest
well i i mean it's conquest you look at
the movie the patriot with mel gibson
which is a fantastic movie and they talk
about the the you know what did he call
it i don't know the the
wilderness campaign the really brutal
stuff that this guy did
there's there's probably stuff you're
never gonna hear because the people who
won were probably like don't tell them
what we had to do to win give them a
good victory story it's actually why i
like the movie fury if you've seen that
one oh really you haven't seen that so
this is the movie any of you guys you
know no so brad pitt um i think shia
labeouf is in it a couple other people
um and it just show it's it's the story
of like one tank one tank unit uh in
europe and it's just
the it's the mud and the grit and the
dirt and like some kid comes up with you
know with an rpg and they've gotta shoot
the kid right or else he's gonna blow up
the tank and kill everybody and it's
just it's dirty and it's nasty and
there's this one
this one part where brad pitt has and
they have the german right and so a
child above has just joined the unit um
is kind of the plot of it and they've
got this nazi that they've captured and
they're like in brad pitt's like we
ain't got no room for prisoners here
would say this ain't command this ain't
a prisoner unit he's like you got
like he he's got a job his job is
killing you you got a job your job is
killing him are you going to do your job
are you going to let him do his job and
it's it's just like all these various
scenes like that culminating you know
the first thing he has to do is wash his
buddy's like face and guts out of the
tank because he's taken that scene yeah
i've seen that movie it was very oh yeah
now
99 of warfare was like yeah and and
there's also the bombing of dresden
which also
goes unaddressed and not talked about
what fdr knew about you know the camps
there's so much history that again we
just aren't privy to and there's so much
evidence
who infiltrated auschwitz twice was
writing reports from the 19 in the early
40s back to so polish underground
intelligence officer infiltrates
auschwitz
sets up literally a radio relay from
inside the camp to get it out to the
polish underground they send the reports
back to the to the british the british
put it on a shelf yep thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm now
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time